we always think that everybody's shining
light on us they we always think it's
all about us but really they're the
stars of their own movie they are not
looking at you
have you ever tried to write under a pen
name where you felt like you could
really
just let it all go and no one's going to
judge you or you wiki we don't need to
know the penny
no i don't think i've ever
i do know that i think
years and years and years ago i'd
written a screenplay
and
i submitted it to someone to read under
a different name just because i thought
it was
it was a little tricky situation
um
and i didn't get any response so i was
like okay that's fine and in retrospect
it was not
it was again it was a very concept-y
idea it was a very scribble comedy kind
of thing but i hadn't done any of the
work i wasn't you know i needed 30 years
to bake
before
that kind of thing was was willing to
come out in the right way
but no i haven't thought about a pen
name i think this for me though again
i'm at an age now where
i don't care
so
and even i've offered to let my kids
read my stuff and it doesn't you know
they're adults so you know we watch hbo
together so
what am i going to say that's not you
know that's not already out there i
don't think that there's anything that i
could expose that
that isn't
you know
exposable
sure you know as a human being i think
we all go through a lot of those same
things i think the failure would be on
my part if i didn't
right
like they wanted what are you doing it
for
yeah but i mean even barring some
heinous crime
still people
you know there's there's there's going
to be judgment unfortunately and and
being okay with that is a really
interesting place to get to sure and i'm
not even talking about you know doing
something horrible but just
you know
whatever it is and and
um but who cares about the judgment
i mean ultimately
i don't i
you know let me just say this i had i
had a big
um
fight with myself when i wrote this book
i brought the book yeah so i i had a big
fight with myself when i wrote this book
because you know it is it is sort of
semi-memorised it's very
you know personal
in a lot of ways but it's also
hopefully a manual to
navigating some of the craziness that is
hollywood right
and for me the biggest challenge was not
even writing the book it was the moment
where
i realized that the book was going to go
out right now all of a sudden
everything is
exposed you know so i
of course went through panic and then
the other part of the panic was
i i had to have a social media presence
and i was not good i was the worst
facebook friend on the planet i did not
do
twitter at all i did not do instagram i
was never on linkedin it was just
uh an annoyance you know and i
and my publisher said
you need to have a social media presence
and i went oh
all i'd seen on social media was
was people bashing other people i didn't
see any support love you know
camaraderie i see it now i see it
i'm on some of the screen screenwriter
and the writer
you know
chat rooms or whatever and i don't even
know what you call them chat rooms
the the threads
and uh and people are incredibly
supportive which i just love
but
i did not really want to put myself
out for that kind of exposure because
the vitriol
can be
damaging right
but ultimately i realized that
i was getting in my way for no reason no
good reason because there will always be
a percentage of people maybe ten percent
of people who right away when you post
something they will come back and
they're usually the first ones who post
that say something negative or they
contradict you they come up with the you
know you say blue and they go no no it's
actually not blue um and there's there's
always that and i was afraid of that
terrified of that
and
and i just really had to get over myself
because i thought something my
grandmother used to say which is um
and she just passed away maybe a year
ago she said uh ain't nobody looking at
you
and that really struck resonated with me
because i thought yeah we always think
that everybody's shining light on us
they we always think it's all about us
but really they're the stars of their
own movie they are not looking at you
so
i really had to get out of my way and go
okay
there may be some of that that comes
back and that's okay
but for the most part if somebody finds
value in this
that's worth it right it's worth it if
one more person
navigates a situation where they're
coming to pitch or they're going to
reach out to an executive or they're
going to a panel and they don't know
what to say
and they want to you know ask a question
at the q a or they want to network at an
event
or whatever they're getting notes from
somebody if that one person can find
some value and can navigate it a little
bit
more and
get through the finish line a little bit
quicker
then that's what the whole point of the
book was and then the book has succeeded
so
sometimes you just gotta
get out of your own way and
and realize that
i don't know that it it matters in the
grand scheme of things 100 years from
now who's going to
or they might care in a good way they
might care a good way you know um so
what point do you feel like
then you were able to go okay the book's
coming out and that's a good thing and
not be terrified or or maybe i mean it's
scary
i don't know that i
i think i
i think i got over the fear
of all that when people started to say
oh i've seen your
posts and i really like them or i really
enjoyed the whatever you you know i i
think too it might have been i did this
thing i did the piece as a piece for a
variety
um
cynthia littleton was so great about it
and i i said you know i'd called her up
and i said hey i've been thinking about
posting this
piece about diversity
and
would you like to take a look at it and
she goes yeah and then she calls me back
she goes i'd like to run this
and i was
and the feedback that i got from people
was was wonderful and i think with every
little step where you gain a little bit
more confidence you go okay i did that
maybe i can do this and maybe i can post
the fact that i'm writing a novel on my
my on this blog
and maybe i can you know
do something about the oscars that just
happened maybe i can just sort of
venture out a little bit more and when
you don't fall off the cliff and you get
up the next day and the sun at sun is
still shining and you realize that
you're still breathing it's not that bad
and you just have to keep going i think
that to
if you think about your whole career i
certainly think about this in my career
and you think about how it's really just
a matter of you putting one step in
front of the other right one foot in
front of the other until you get
someplace and you don't think about it
at the time
but then you look back and you go wow i
did that
and i did not know where i was going but
look at where i am today
i started a non-profit back in 2000 with
a friend of mine bruce evans
and we did not realize that 22 years
later we would still have this
non-profit
and that it would be impacting people's
lives like crazy we just did one little
thing at a time it was we took some
people to dinner and then we took a
couple more people to dinner and then we
connected more people and then we did
mentoring programs and um and invited
you know major studio network heads to
join this group and
and then we sort of now we're doing a
leadership program so it's it's organic
it happened
slowly
but it's just one little piece at a time
i think it's also like raising children
you know i had one kid and then i had
two more kids and you just keep
factoring them in until you
you learn how to do it better
but i do think that there's a a
progression that happens
naturally and automatically
and
you're never quite sure where it's going
to end up you can have an idea and then
you know either those
that that pathway opens up for you it
doesn't open up for you and you find a
new pathway
just like writing executive
you know career back to writing